so uh then the strength training i think
is maybe the other aspect because
i mean for myself i remember i was doing
an 18 mile training run and
i had done some deadlifting and you know
you know basically like a lot of
posterior work glutes and hamstrings a
few days before the run and i was still
a little sore and i went running and i
mean that another another thing i want
to ask about is heat because i'm i live
in arizona so scottsdale is very hot and
so i was running at like 6 to 9 a.m 6 30
to 9 30 in the morning and i know i know
you're so fast um but i you know it's
very hot here so i mean i wear actually
it's you can see the tan line probably
from my watch but i wear a garmin and
you know it was peaking at like 109
degrees and so you know between having
posterior soreness from strength
training as well as then the heat which
those are two separate things um it was
a it was a disaster strain training is
important you know obviously you know
the ligaments and the muscles need to be
strengthened to carry you 13.1 miles or
26.2 miles and you know you just got to
be
just like a strategy race you got to
strategize want to do them also because
you don't want to do them after you're
doing 60 mile run or you know on the
easy days you want to be able to do it
you know sometimes you got to change
your long runs or your intensity because
you did not feel like you were up to it
or happy to get the best out of yourself
so that that means if the training
core training is the next day you don't
want to do the long run or intervals and
then go stick to that routine you have
to be flexible to be able to change but
you know as much as you know weight your
body weight is good or the bars you just
want to get those muscles
kind of limbery and really um
cancel up a little bit to be able to
help you carry the carry the direction i
think i'm you know the
dyna disc or what the medicine ball is
important doing the curls or hamstring
curls in the in the medicine ball is
very important to be instead of going to
a gym and be able to
lift big weights because you know 26.2
miles is a long ways but at the same
time you want to be able to just nurture
those muscles as healthy as possible and
you know do it in a fun way you know and
the push-ups suit up score important is
very important i mean
i can hear stay here and talk to you all
about that stuff but i have a book
called methyl mortals that tells you all
about the strength training and
conditioning and crash training because
as a distance runners we cannot
sometimes we are prone to injuries and
you have to prevent it if it becomes big
problems so taking a day off going for a
swim or taking a day off or going an
elliptical ride is important those
things instead of hey it's on my
schedule i gotta do it don't try to be
to the book you know as much as you can
you try to but at the same time if you
have to know what is best for danica to
be able to say you know what coach or
team i need to take a day off today
because thanks to now i just leave water
last night so that 16 mile run we're
going to do tomorrow or the next day
versus say forcing it and sticking the
rigid to it it can it can prone to be a
little bit of a problem so you gotta be
flexible but at the same time strength
training is just important to be able to
get to your posture you know i don't
know if you wear sunglasses but uh
you gotta wear your glasses hopefully
during the during the run as well so
that way because we get fatigue i use my
maui gym to be able to just when i'm
running because when you fatigue your
head goes down but if you have
sunglasses
this for the whole time so it won't slip
so that's another tradition that i'm
sharing with you oh man
actually that was something witnessed is
that i kind of run a little like chest
down and i i
i really try to concentrate on that
after it was pointed out um but i don't
wear sunglasses and i and i probably
will wear a hat but i i actually i mean
i never wear a hat either my eyes are
not very sensitive and so i think to
myself i don't really squint that much
but it is probably some level of a drain
and it's also
a little bit of a it's like a it's
almost like wearing some you know people
will tape their bodies in areas that are
sore it like reminds you to have the
right sort of posture as you said so
interesting i don't know if i'll wear
sunglasses because i'm almost down to
the wire
and i don't know which ones wouldn't
bother me but in the future if i were to
ever do a marathon again i will train
with sunglasses for that
that um body position reason that's a
that's a great one um you know even
though you know you don't wear glasses
but you gotta cons constantly thinking
you know shake the hands like you know
just let them loose every
5k or every four mile just let you know
because you know you're running like
this just let them down the block will
come in but also
thinking about you know wearing
sunglasses about to say how's my posture
you got to think okay how's my posture
am i staying tall you know just imagine
you have an egg on top of your head you
don't want to tilt it whatever you just
want to be tall and that's going to help
you just do that maybe every
10k or something they don't have to do
it four or five times and that's when
you'll be okay i mean you you're you
have so many different modalities you
became such a
you know
insanely accomplished highly tuned
athlete and you took it so seriously
but i want to go back to
how you got that way
and
you know hearing your story about
uh growing up in
uh atreya and
living by living without your family
from five to ten years old and then
moving to italy i mean you've had quite
a path
and i i'm wondering like first off what
do you what is your family like how did
how did that go so you got separated at
five years old and and did you did you
get were you back together with them
when when you were 10
so and
thanks for bringing that up with danica
and around to overcome my autobiography
i discuss about how i was born in
eritrea and my dad has to flee from
eritrea to sudan because he was wanted
by the ethiopian soldier so he was going
to get prison or kill so my mom has to
kind of have a hard talk just tell him
hey you might want to take this chance
you know it's not like you get a flight
but he has to go over 225 miles in the
wilderness and sometimes he has to spend
the night and the trees on top of the
tree and the branch because
you know you know if he's on the ground
there's hyenas lions scorpions and other
animals that can take his life so he
survived it but uh you know my
my parents had five kids and one on the
way and uh they told him to say if
there's a girl call her the imnet or
[Music]
which it means with belief that one day
if i make it a safe land i would look
after you so i did not see my father
from the age of five till i was ten and
my mom and i brothers and sisters grew
up in a third world country not
electricity no running water where we
have to fetch the woods to have fire so
we can cook meals and we've got two to
three miles to get that and in fact one
day i was in the vicinity of another
border and i got caught unfortunately
and trying to get as much uh
uh woods like as i can and i got caught
and my my you know we have to spend the
whole day there and my mom has to come
and bail us out with the about the water
bottle size of grains to like a bail
bond almost would allow us to escape and
then you've got to go two to three miles
to go to get to the water out of the
well and you know carry it on yourself
or put it on a donkey to be able to do
that so but fortunately my dad made it
and we didn't see him for five years and
there was great people who helped us
escape from eritrea um dr brendiche
his boss and later michael who's my my
sister ruth's mom i have half sister
ruth and they work together to be able
to escape and i remember there's so many
generosity people in the world and my
dad asked his boss if he could lend him
this in 1986 if he could lend him a 10
10 million lyric
italian italian money at the time was
six thousand u.s dollars and he says is
that to save some one one person or to
save everybody and my dad said you know
with the money that i have and worked it
would save everybody and dr brendichi
his boss said come back wednesday and he
came back on wednesday and he gave him
10 million litre cash and he says this
is not alone it's a gift that's how we
got saved and
that's how we made it until from eritrea
to italy and we lived in italy for a
year and a half and
i saw tv for the first time
as a 10 year old i did not understand
how people fit in that side that tv so i
went behind the tv to see if they were
there and
that's
humble beginning but you know
fortunately we came to the united states
on october 21st 1987 and uh we worked
hard and you know how were you done
i was 12th grade i'm sorry fourth year
old in seventh grade so my oldest
brother had the most difficult because
he was placed without we didn't speak
english so we were just placed by our
age we didn't have any my brothers had a
little bit more education than i did but
so you are 15 years old you're gonna be
in uh ninth grade or twelfth year all
yourself was in seventh grade but they
luckily for me they put me in elementary
for one year just i can learn english
and the following year in 2000
1988 i was
in p class in san diego next to the san
diego zoo if you ever there check it out
roosevelt junior high middle school and
then he said if you run hard you're
going to get a or b make sure you take
the smile run seriously he told the
whole class and my parents always
expected an a for them class and i had
two older brothers who ran for roosevelt
junior high and they had the roosevelt
roosevelt junior high my club shirt and
i wanted to be like them and so when the
questions go i just ran as hard as i can
it wasn't on the track four times it was
around the baseball field around the
softball field and then go to the middle
of the campus down the ramp and finish
up the ramp and
to get the tissue and a to get the
t-shirt and now you have to run
6 15 and i end up running 520 and he
goes
he can't believe it he's like he called
the high school coach and uh he says
this guy's going to go to the olympics
he said you're going to go to the
olympic but i'm like um did i get a
t-shirt
you're like do i get an a and do i get a
t-shirt yeah i don't know what the word
olympic man i'm just really learning my
english so i have no idea and i went and
asked my dad that evening that says
what's the olympics and he said what'd
you do what happened he's like of course
duke lord says i ran i've gone with the
olympics in my native tongue obviously
and he goes well the olympics are every
four years and they guess peace and
harmony different continents and
countries get together for a friendly
competition and
and the rest is history
after that i got my t-shirt my a and i
started making friends high-fiving
people and you know my picture was in
the gym and
you know they said i was known as a
faster seventh grader